how to bounce back after failure
so i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
who was ed d who wrote in to say hey
evan hypothetically speaking
say you started a new business it was a
complete failure gained
a tone of something that was some ways
to get you back on your feet and start
another business both emotionally and
physically so
anyways wonder how do i get back on my
feet after i fail what's the best way to
do an emotion physically
this is a great question because a lot
of entrepreneurs deal with failure and
you will know
failure everybody will know failure
before you achieve success
for me there are two types of failure
the first is going to be where you've
started a business and you shut it down
completely shut it down moved on and did
something else
the second is you're in your business
and
what's what you're trying to do right
now isn't working and you need to change
your model you change what you're
selling
change how you're selling it says all
these failures that you reach before you
have success
and if you look at the stories of famous
entrepreneurs you'll find that they all
went through the same things like
every entrepreneur had failures before
they became successful
so here's what will help you okay and it
centers around
belief no surprise coming from me the
first part is
believe that you're doing the right
thing a lot of times the failed
companies you started for
not the right motives you started just
trying to make a lot of money you
started because you
still thought it'd be a great
opportunity but you didn't start it
because
you had a burning passion for this and
that's where most businesses will fail
you have to really believe that you're
doing the right thing like this is
something that is needed
and you are going to will this thing
into into creation it needs to be done
you love it that much
the second is believe that you can do it
you know i think that's going to be one
of the hardest parts if all you've had
is failure in your life believe that you
can do it
and the easiest way that i found to
start getting that belief back in
yourself is small wins
because when you see this huge gap in
where you want to go where you want to
be and where you are now you see this
massive gap
and that can be so so scary
and you have no track record to say that
you can bridge that gap
that you you're just you know
you're listening to the little man you
are just mired in self-defeat and you
think there's no way i can get there
the way to do that is to make the steps
smaller and you go one step
and then that's easy enough to do again
and another step but another step but
another step
until you've gone all the way and you
don't realize what a big step you've
taken
anything that you're gonna do that's
that's worthwhile doing is going to come
with a healthy dose of fear
and i remember just as an example you
know my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs and
i was invited to speak in brunei one
year
in asia and i didn't realize how big an
event was going to be it was going to be
uh you know huge room like a thousand
people it's going to be broadcast on
their national television
and i was nervous you know and i
secretly wish that they would call me
and say
but it's off you don't have to come
forget that you know the day before
some big thing you secretly wish it
would be canceled
and i realized you know what this is
this is important for our mission
and i got out there i did a great job i
loved it it was such a high such a rush
and
i left feeling like i could do that
again like that was scary for me the
first time
but i could do it again i could do it
again i could do it again so push
yourself to take these little steps
and you'll gain confidence and greater
belief in yourself to be able to go up
and do
you know eventually achieve that gap
and the last one is believe that that it
can be done and
a lot of times all you'll see is
darkness around you a lot of times
you may not you know have the full
confidence that this thing is going to
work out
and what really helped me with that is
reading the stories of famous
entrepreneurs i love famous
entrepreneurs stories i love the bios i
love seeing how they got started
and all of them had this belief that it
was going to work out and reading their
stories and seeing how they failed and
seeing how nobody believed in them and
seeing how they had all these crisis
you look at them now i think of any
entrepreneur you look at jobs or disney
or
gates or whoever it is when they started
it looked like they had no hope
and they turned something amazing out of
it
and so reading those stories of the
early days made me
believe that even though it doesn't make
sense quite yet now
that the dots will line up in my future
then it will work out and you have to
have that same belief
so hopefully that helps my three steps
to helping you get back on your feet
and maybe one final one is know that
you're not alone you know it's dirty
secret of entrepreneurship is that
nobody likes to talk about their
failures you only talk about the wins
right you're meeting somebody in the
face saying
here's all the great stuff that happened
but nobody says ah man
i'm thinking of shutting down this
company i don't know what to do
everybody's had failures everybody's
been through this you are not alone
and you can come through if you believe
thank you guys for watching you liked
the video give it a thumbs up below
you want to leave a comment you have a
question for me leave it below
wish me to feel better leave it below uh
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel
and thank you so much i'll see